I've made a number of movies about
people who have spent time in the
military John
but Sergeant John Kinley is different
from any character that I've played
Jade's performances are always very
captivating and the choices he makes are
different from what you would expect
don't ever override my authority again
we understand each other
yes
[Music]
I'm constantly surprised like his
ability to ratchet that tension
and then twine the viewer within that
drama in a special forces team we have
to work together as a new name and Jade
stepped into that very naturally I have
a deep respect for the military because
I know that it requires so much more to
wear the uniform
than I could ever do as a performer
[Music]